PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
(screaming)
13 FINALISTS MOVED INTO
THEIR NEW HOME IN BEL AIR.
(screaming)
CASSANDRA REVEALED SOME
INTERESTING FACETS
OF HER PERSONALITY...
YOU KNOW HOW SOCIOPATHS
DON'T FEEL EMOTION,
AND THAT'S WHY
THEY CAN KILL PEOPLE
WITHOUT EVER FEELING
BAD ABOUT IT?
ONLY I NEVER
KILLED ANYBODY.
THE GIRLS FLEW HIGH IN
THEIR SUPERHERO PHOTO SHOOT.
GORGEOUS.
SARAH.
WHEN ASHLEY FAILED TO MAKE
A GOOD IMPRESSION,
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
12 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT?
♪&♪&♪&
(alarm rings)
BEING ALMOST ELIMINATED,
IT WAS SHOCKING.
I ACTUALLY AM
JUST REALLY RELIEVED.
I'M JUST GONNA HAVE TO GET
BETTER THAN I AM
SINCE WHAT I AM ISN'T
GOOD ENOUGH RIGHT NOW.
MORNING. WHAT UP?
YEAH, IT'S WEIRD.
BUT I DIDN'T THINK THAT
SHE WAS GONNA BE IT AT ALL.
I AM SO COMPETITIVE, AND
I'M TRYING TO MAKE, LIKE,
SOMETHING
GREAT FOR MYSELF.
YOU CAN'T UNDERESTIMATE
FOR ONE SECOND,
ONE OF THESE SKEEZERS HERE.
YOU CAN'T.
IF YOU SHOW WEAKNESS,
THEY'RE GONNA POUNCE ON YOU
LIKE A PACK OF HYENAS
TO A CARCASS.
- TYRA MAIL.
"DON'T BITCH AND MOAN
ABOUT THIS HAIRY SITUATION.
BE READY AND LEAVE
AT 8:45 A.M."
YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS.
MAKEOVERS.
I'M SO CONFIDENT
IN THE WAY I LOOK,
AND I THINK I PRESENT
MYSELF VERY WELL.
I HAVE A GREAT NATURAL BEAUTY,
AND I DON'T THINK I REALLY NEED
TO CHANGE MUCH TO ENHANCE THAT.
- HEY, HEY, HEY.
- HEY.
HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD.
ARE YOU ALL READY
TO BITCH AND MOAN
- ABOUT A HAIR SITUATION?
- NO.
WELL, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE, RIGHT?
YOU'RE IN A HAIR SALON,
BUT NOT JUST ANY HAIR SALON.
YOU'RE IN THE LOUIS LICARI
HAIR SALON.
THIS IS MR. LOUIS
LICARI HIMSELF.
HE IS A LEGEND.
HE IS THE MASTER OF COLOR.
HE IS THE COLORIST
TO EVERY STAR,
TONS OF SUPERMODELS,
AND WE HAVE AN IDEA
FOR EVERYBODY.
WE'RE GONNA TURN YOU GIRLS
INTO THESE BLING TOP MODELS.
I MEAN, LIKE LINDA EVANGELISTA
BECAME A HUGE SUPERMODEL
WHEN SHE CUT
HER HAIR ALL SHORT.
ALL RIGHTY, I'M GONNA
START WITH NICOLE.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
HAIR WEAVE AND MAKE YOU
EVEN MORE CURLY AND MORE
FABULOUS AND MORE VOLUME.
THAT SOUNDS GREAT.
CORYN, YOU'RE GONNA
ACTUALLY BE A BLONDE.
OH, MY GOD.
DIANE, WE ARE GOING
TO GIVE YOU A WHEAT COLOR,
LIKE ON A PRAIRIE.
- OKAY.
- LET ME SEE LISA.
I THINK THAT THE HAIR
SHOULD GIVE MORE CONTRAST
TO THE EYE COLOR.
IF WE CAN MAKE YOUR HAIR COLOR
RICHER, CHOCOLATEY,
ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOUR BLUE
EYES ARE JUST GOING TO POP.
I'M LIKE LINDA EVANGELISTA,
MAN, I'M A CHAMELEON.
COME ON. I WANT
SOMETHING REALLY DRASTIC.
EBONY, WE THOUGHT AND THOUGHT
AND THEN WE SAID,
SHE NEEDS GLAMOUR,
SHE NEEDS PIZZAZZ,
AND SHE NEEDS TO REPRESENT
HER PEOPLE, GIRL.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE BRAIDS
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO HERE.
AAH!
KYLE, WE'RE GONNA MAKE
YOUR HAIR CHOCOLATEY BROWN.
OKAY.
- JAYLA...
- BRING IT ON.
WE WANT TO TAKE YOU FROM
HERE TO HERE, HONEY.
- YES!
- KIM.
YES, TYRA?
I'M DEFINITELY NOT EXPECTING
TO GET MY HAIR,
LIKE, BUZZED OFF OR
SOMETHING BECAUSE, I MEAN,
YOU CAN'T HAVE A LESBIAN
WITH BUZZED HAIR.
IT'S, LIKE, TOO MUCH.
WE LOVE THE LENGTH
OF YOUR HAIR,
BUT YOU HAVE THIS
KIND OF OLIVEY-COLORED SKIN
THAT I THINK WOULD BE
GREAT RED.
PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO BE RED
CHOOSE TO BE NOTICED,
- SO WATCH OUT.
- HEY!
SARAH...
SARAH, WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
AN EDGY, SYMMETRICAL HAIRCUT.
OKAY.
NIK, YOU HAVE SUCH
A HONEY-COLORED COMPLEXION,
AND WE THOUGHT YOUR HAIR
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
TOO DARK FOR THAT, SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE YOU BRIGHTER.
WE'RE GONNA
MAKE YOU SUN-KISSED.
BRE, WE'RE GONNA JUST
STRAIGHTEN YOU OUT
AND MAKE YOU
BONE STRAIGHT AND SEXY.
CASSANDRA,
YOU HAVE POISE.
YOU ARE A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN,
BUT IN THAT JUDGING ROOM,
ALL THE ANSWERS ARE RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU'RE A BEAUTY QUEEN,
AND IT'S KIND OF BLAND.
IT'S SAFE.
IT'S LIKE, WHO IS THE REAL
GIRL UP UNDER ALL THAT HAIR?
SO YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M DOING?
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THAT MOVIE
"ROSEMARY'S BABY"
STARRING MIA FARROW?
YOU HAVEN'T?
I'LL EXPLAIN WHAT HER HAIR
LOOKED LIKE IN THAT MOVIE.
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT
LIGHTER THAN YOURS,
AND IT WAS THIS SHORT.
OH, MY GOSH.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SAY
BYE-BYE TO BEAUTY QUEEN.
WE'RE NOT JUST CUTTING THIS
JUST TO CUT YOUR HAIR.
- OH, NO.
- THIS FITS YOUR FACE.
YOUR FACE IS STRONG ENOUGH
TO HANDLE THAT.
CASSANDRA,
WHY ARE YOU CRYING?
I LOVE MY HAIR.
IT'LL ALWAYS GROW BACK.
THAT SUCKS FOR HER,
BUT IT'S LIKE,
YOU REALLY GOTTA DO
WHAT YOU GOTTA DO,
'CAUSE THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
OF A LIFETIME.
ALSO WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA BE DOING
IS A PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REPRESENTING THESE LOOKS
BUT TO THE TENTH POWER
AT THAT PHOTO SHOOT.
AND ON TOP OF THAT,
I'M GONNA GO AROUND
AND GIVE EACH ONE OF YOU
YOUR OWN STYLE TO ADOPT.
ALL RIGHT,
ARE YOU GUYS READY?
YEAH.
ALL RIGHTY,
WE'RE GONNA START NOW!
YAY! BYE.
I'M SO EXCITED RIGHT NOW.
I'VE ALWAYS HAD
MY HAIR. ALWAYS.
AND NOW IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE GONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEN IT NEEDS TO GO.
IF YOU'VE GOT YOUR HAIR
LIKE THAT ALL YOUR WHOLE LIFE,
THEN IT NEEDS TO GO.
DAMN, LIKE,
YOU WANT TO TRADE?
LIKE, YOU COULD STAY
THE BEAUTY QUEEN THAT YOU ARE
IF YOU WANT TO.
LOOK, YOU'LL FEEL
SO BEAUTIFUL. COME ON.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE CASSANDRA
SHOW SOME EMOTION.
SHE'S BASICALLY BEEN
A ROBOT THIS ENTIRE TIME,
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
ANYONE HAS SEEN HER DO ANYTHING
THAT'S EVEN REMOTELY CLOSE
TO BEING HUMAN.
- YOU READY?
- NO.
- YOU'RE GONNA LOOK AWESOME.
- COME ON. OKAY.
I DON'T WANT TO WATCH.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
BYE-BYE. IT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE READY.
NO MORE BEAUTY PAGEANTS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU ARE GONNA LOOK SO GREAT.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW.
IT'S JUST A REALLY
BIG SHOCK.
BUT WAIT, YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU TOLD US IN CASTING?
I'M REALLY EASY TO WORK WITH,
AND I THINK THAT
THE PHOTOGRAPHERS AND
MAKEUP ARTISTS WOULD LOVE ME
BECAUSE I WILL DO
WHAT YOU TELL ME.
YOU GOTTA TRUST US,
SERIOUSLY.
I AM. IT'S JUST
TAKING A LOT OUT OF ME.
I MEAN, I DID IT.
DID YOU EVER SEE THE MOVIE
"ROSEMARY'S BABY"?
- NO.
- MIA FARROW.
IT'S A PRETTY FREAKY MOVIE.
- SHE'S, LIKE, PREGNANT.
- WITH THE DEVIL'S BABY?
- OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT?
WHAT'S SO FEMININE
ABOUT RED HAIR?
DO YOU THINK I LOOK
REALLY FEMININE?
NO, I DON'T THINK IT IS.
NO, I DON'T.
YOU KNOW, I'M TRYING
TO MAINTAIN, LIKE,
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPRESSION,
AND, LIKE,
THAT MIGHT BE HARD
WITH THIS COLOR.
NO BOY HAS THIS COLOR HAIR.
SO, YOU'RE NOT A BOY.
- YOU'RE A MASCULINE...
- YEAH, BUT IT'S LIKE MY THING.
ACTUALLY, WE SHOULD HAVE
WORKED ON THE NOSE HAIRS. LOOK.
IF YOU GOT SCISSORS, JUST GO...
(imitates cutting sound)
HOW LONG IS THIS GONNA TAKE
TO DO ALL THIS HAIR TODAY?
IT'S GONNA TAKE A COOL
MINUTE, TO PUT IT MILDLY.
I CAN'T WAIT TO START
PLAYING WITH IT.
IT'S BEEN 12 HOURS
OF HER CRYING.
THEY WANT TO BE
SOMEBODY THAT I'M NOT.
AND WHAT? WHY DO I
WANNA DO THIS?
I'M JUST GOING THROUGH
WITH ALL THE GIRLS
HOW THEY CAN
INCORPORATE THEIR STYLE
WITH THEIR NEW MAKEOVER.
YOU'RE A LITTLE MORE LIKE
THE GHETTO FAB GIRL.
I GUESS THAT JUST MEANS THAT
I'M FABULOUS ONE WAY OR ANOTHER,
BECAUSE THERE WAS NOTHING
DRASTICALLY DONE TO ME.
THEN NOBODY CAN
COME UP WITH A CONCLUSION
OF HOW TO MAKE ME
MORE BEAUTIFUL.
JAY TOLD ME THAT
MY NEW LOOK IS GONNA BE,
LIKE, '90s SUPERMODEL,
KIND OF LIKE
THE WIDE-EYED SUPERMODEL.
I LOVE LONG, THICK HAIR,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I GOT.
I'M REALLY PUMPED UP
ABOUT IT.
I WANT YOU TO, LIKE,
EVOKE THE EARLY SUPERMODELS.
OKAY.
SERIOUSLY, I DIDN'T EVEN THINK
THIS COULD LOOK THIS GOOD.
I'D ACTUALLY REALLY SEE YOU
AS A RALPH LAUREN GIRL.
I DIDN'T KNOW I COULD
LOOK THIS WAY.
I FEEL LIKE I LOOK
A MILLION TIMES BETTER,
AND IT'S EASIER
TO MANAGE.
I JUST LOVE IT IN GENERAL.
I'M THE ONLY PERSON
WHO'S BEEN TOLD
TO STAY COMPLETELY
IN MY PERSONAL STYLE.
YOUR SENSE OF STYLE BEFORE
WAS A LITTLE BIT ROCKER GIRL.
BUT WE WANNA MAKE YOU LOOK
A LITTLE MORE CHIC.
I WANTED BLOND HAIR,
AND I WANTED IT LONG,
BUT I AT LEAST GOT
THE LONG HAIR.
STYLIST HOOKED ME UP.
SHE MADE ME LOOK BEAUTIFUL,
SO I'M HAPPY WITH IT.
I WANTED YOU TO START
THINKING OF YOURSELF
AS A SOPHISTICATED GIRL.
I NEVER WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
BLONDE AT ALL,
BUT OVERALL
I LIKE MY MAKEOVER.
YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE THAT
SOPHISTICATED YOUNG MODEL,
SO YOU BRING NOTICE TO YOURSELF
BY BEING FASHIONABLY CASUAL.
I LOVE
THE FINISHED PRODUCT.
IT'S AMAZING.
YOU'RE NOT
THE SOPHISTICATED GIRL.
YOU'RE NOT THE FASHION
FORWARD GIRL.
YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE
THE BOHEMIAN CHIC.
YOU'VE GOT TEXTURE
AND YOU GOT THE COLOR.
IT'S COOL, IT'S DIFFERENT
AND IT DEFINITELY
ATTRACTS ATTENTION.
THAT WAS A LOT OF WORK
TO SIT THROUGH THAT.
I LOVE IT.
I JUST GOT IN THE CHAIR
AND I KNEW
I WAS GONNA BE SITTING,
AND IT TOOK 13 HOURS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IT LOOKED SO AWESOME,
SO I DIDN'T REALLY CARE
THAT I COULDN'T FEEL
MY LEGS OR MY BUTT.
I WANT YOU TO WORK
WITH YOUR NEW LOOK.
OBVIOUSLY, I'M STILL GONNA
BE A FEMININE PERSON
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I AM.
WHAT BOTHERED ME MOST ABOUT
THE MAKEOVER IS JAY SAID,
"NO, YOU CAN'T ACT
FEMININE ANYMORE."
A LOT MORE KIND OF MOD.
A LITTLE MORE EDGY.
"YOU HAVE TO ACT EDGY."
SO YOU GUYS HAVE HAD
THE MAKEOVERS.
I TALKED WITH EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
ABOUT WHAT YOUR NEW STYLE
SHOULD BE,
SO YOU NEED
TO START TO ADOPT THAT
SO YOU TAKE ON THAT SUPERMODEL,
TOP MODEL PERSONA.
- WORK IT OUT.
- THANK YOU, JAY.
TYRA MAIL.
"GET READY TO RACK UP
SOME FASHION CRED.
BE READY AT..."
READY, GUYS?
- 6:30 A.M.
- OHH!
FABULOUS. FABULOUS.
I THINK
WE'RE GOING SHOPPING,
BECAUSE THIS IS FASHION CRED,
SO I THINK FASHION CREDIT.
NOBODY BELIEVES ME.
MAYBE I SHOULD SLEEP
WITH MY PONYTAIL
UNDER MY PILLOW.
OH, GOD, WHY?
BECAUSE I MISS MY HAIR.
MAYBE SOMEWHERE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
AND I FEEL IT ON MY SHOULDER,
IT'LL BE COMFORTING.
I'M COMPLAINING.
ALL I WANNA DO IS TALK
ABOUT MY HAIR.
MAKE EVERYTHING ABOUT MY HAIR.
I CAN'T PLAY WITH MY HAIR.
WHEN I GO TO BRUSH MY TEETH,
AND I LOOK IN THE MIRROR,
IT'S GONNA BE--
IT'S NOT GONNA BE PRETTY.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF GIRLS
WHO STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY I GOT SO UPSET
ABOUT IT, BUT THEY SHOULD.
MY HAIR, MY HAIR, MY HAIR.
IT SUCKS.
THE WAY
CASSANDRA HAS ACTED
MIGHT PUT HER AT STAKE
FOR ELIMINATION.
WE'LL SEE HOW FAR I GET AND
WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH THIS HAIR
IS REALLY GONNA WORK FOR ME.
WE'LL SEE.
I'VE NEVER HEARD ANYONE
COMPLAIN SO MUCH IN MY LIFE.
IT'S LIKE A JOKE.
IT WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
THE PHONE'S WORKING."
SHE'S LIKE, "WELL, GOOD,
I HAVE TO USE IT,
BECAUSE I HAVE TO
TELL PEOPLE ABOUT THIS."
AND IT'S JUST LIKE,
"DUDE, SHUT UP."
CASSANDRA WAS NOT
ADAPTING WELL TO HER HAIR,
AND I THINK THAT MIGHT
HURT HER IN THIS.
WE HAD OUR MAKEOVERS
YESTERDAY.
- Oh, yeah?
- YEAH.
How do you look?
YOU'RE GOING TO HATE IT.
(groans)
THE TYRA MAIL SAID,
"YOU KNOW, RACK UP
SOME FASHION CRED."
AND WE'RE LIKE, "OKAY,
LIKE, WE'RE READY."
COME ON, LET'S GO.
WE WERE IN THE LUXE HOTEL
ON RODEO DRIVE,
AND WE'RE ON THE ROOFTOP.
AND IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL
AND THE STREETS ARE JUST,
LIKE, AMAZINGLY CLEAN.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
♪&♪&♪&
THIS BALD GUY
WITH MAKEUP COMES OUT,
AND HE'S WEARING WHAT LOOKS
TO ME LIKE A CLOWN DRESS.
HELLO, LADIES.
AND HE TELLS US ABOUT
OUR CHALLENGE,
AND I'M STILL THINKING,
"WHAT IS THIS GUY WEARING?"
I'M JAMES ST. JAMES,
CLUB KID EXTRAORDINAIRE,
FASHION PROVOCATEUR AND
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL STYLE.
PERSONAL STYLE MEANS THAT
YOU CAN BE FAT, 40 AND BALD
AND DRESS LIKE A CLOWN
AND STILL BE THE MOST
FABULOUS PERSON IN THE ROOM.
IT MEANS THAT YOU HAVE
A LOOK AND IT MEANS
THAT YOU HAVE A POINT
OF VIEW BEHIND YOUR LOOK.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A PERSONAL STYLE MISSION.
WE'RE GOING TO GO SHOPPING
IN BEVERLY HILLS.
YOU EACH GET $500
TO BUY AN OUTFIT
THAT FITS
YOUR PERSONAL STYLE.
ONLY THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE
GETS TO KEEP THE OUTFIT.
JUST TO REMIND YOU ALL,
THESE ARE BASED ON THE STYLES
THAT JAY GAVE YOU
YESTERDAY.
SO YOU'RE GOING
TO BE BUILDING ON THAT
AND TAKING IT
TO THE EXTREME.
OKAY, SO I WANT YOU ALL
BACK HERE
IN AN HOUR AND A HALF. GO.
AND I'M GOING TO BE CHECKING UP
ON YOU PERIODICALLY, TOO.
NO, RIGHT HERE, RIGHT HERE.
LADIES, HERE I COME!
CLUB MONACO.
- ARE YOU SHOPPING HERE OR NO?
- NO.
OKAY. COME HELP ME.
IT WAS KINDA DIFFICULT
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T--
I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE MOD STYLE
THAT JAY GAVE ME.
- DO YOU THINK IT'S MOD?
- NO.
NO?
HERE I COME, LADIES!
STRAGGLERS WILL BE
PENALIZED.
$29? THAT'S TIGHT.
BOHEMIAN CHIC.
OOH, THIS IS MY STYLE.
WHY ISN'T THIS MY STYLE?
- THESE ARE AWESOME.
- BECAUSE THEY ARE UGLY.
MORE STYLE, MORE GLAMOUR.
FASTER, HURRY!
IF WE GO THIS WAY,
WE'RE GONNA STAY ON BRIGHTON.
WE NEED TO GO ON RODEO.
WE NEED TO GO THAT WAY.
THIS IS IT, GUYS.
I LOVE THIS STYLE.
LOOK AT THIS.
I JUST NEED A TANK TOP.
$20 TANK TOP--
YOU CAN'T BEAT THAT.
NO, YOU REALLY CAN'T.
I AM A WARDROBE
STYLIST ASSISTANT.
I DON'T THINK
THERE IS ANYBODY HERE
THAT TAKES FASHION AS
SERIOUSLY AS I DO.
I AM READY.
EBONY, DID YOU GET
YOUR TANK TOP?
WELL, I THOUGHT THIS WAS $25,
BUT IT WAS $52.
- DO IT.
- ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME.
THAT'S FIERCE.
THEY'RE, LIKE, SO DIVA.
SO...
WITH SOME RED LIPSTICK. OH.
EBONY,
WHAT'S A MOD SHOE?
CASSANDRA--HER LOOK...
DO YOU THINK IT'S MOD?
DO YOU THINK IT'S HIP?
SHE CAN'T HANDLE IT.
YOU THINK THEY'RE MOD?
- YES.
- VERY.
- I NEED THE RECEIPT.
- THANK YOU.
LET'S GO.
YOU GUYS,
WE HAVE TO HAUL ASS.
OH, THAT'S TOTALLY MOD
RIGHT THERE.
WELCOME BACK, LADIES.
I SEE THAT YOU MADE IT
JUST IN THE NICK OF TIME.
NOW AS A PERSONAL STYLE
CHALLENGE, WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
IS TO SEE HOW WELL YOUR NEW
OUTFIT REPRESENTS THE NEW YOU
AND WHAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO BRING TO EACH OUTFIT.
STEP FORWARD AND TELL ME
WHAT YOUR NEW LOOK WAS.
JAY TOLD ME TO DO LIKE
A CHANEL BUT EDGIER.
I LIKE THE SORT OF NEW WAVE
THING HAPPENING THERE.
THAT'S SORT OF CUTE.
YOU HAVE A BOLD FACE.
I THINK YOU CAN WEAR
BIGGER ACCESSORIES.
YOU CAN GO REAL CHUNKY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT'S AS SOPHISTICATED
AS I THINK JAY WANTED IT.
JAY TOLD ME TO LOOK
MOD AND HIPSTER.
HMM. I THINK YOU NEED TO BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE BOLD.
I THINK YOU NEED TO
TAKE A LITTLE MORE RISK.
YOU NEED TO JUST SORT OF--
TO OWN YOUR NEW LOOK.
JAY TOLD ME NOT TO CHANGE
MY PERSONAL STYLE TOO MUCH.
I THINK YOU COULD
STILL EMBRACE
- A LITTLE BIT MORE FEMININITY.
- OKAY.
I WOULD WORRY THAT YOU HAVE
TOO MANY ACCESSORIES GOING ON.
I WOULD LOSE THE SHAWL.
YOU CAN DO PREPPY,
AND YOU CAN DO POLO
- WITHOUT BEING SO WASHED OUT.
- OKAY.
JAY TOLD ME BASICALLY,
LIKE, I AM THE OLD SCHOOL
SUPERMODELS
WITH A LITTLE PUNCH.
I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT'S SUPERMODEL,
BUT I THINK THIS IS
PERSONAL STYLE TO ME.
JAY TOLD ME TO REALLY DO
LIKE AN EDGY SOPHISTICATED.
TWO WORDS. UM, EW,
WITH THE TOP.
I DON'T LIKE THE TOP. UM...
I WAS LIKE, "WHY DID THOSE
GIRLS TELL ME TO BUY THAT?
DOGGONE IT."
SORRY.
MY SHOE JUST BROKE.
WORK IT. USE IT.
AND BE A LITTLE
MORE DECONSTRUCTIVE.
- BE A LITTLE RATTIER.
- OKAY.
THE SHOES-- YOU ALL REALLY
DID GOOD WITH THE SHOES.
THE JACKET IS CUTE,
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
JACKETS ARE SHORTER NOW.
I THINK YOU LOOK FABULOUS.
YOU LOOK FANTASTIC, BUT BE
CAREFUL OF OVERACCESSORIZING.
AND, UM, THE LAST ONE.
THE BELT, I THINK,
IS A LITTLE LIKE '99,
A LITTLE 2000.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT--
IT'S A LITTLE OFF FOR ME.
OKAY, AFTER CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION,
I'VE CHOSEN MY WINNER, AND
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE...
- LISA.
- AAH!
LISA, YOU GET TO CHOOSE
TWO FRIENDS.
ANYONE FROM THE GROUP.
- EBONY, OF COURSE.
SHE PICKED ME AS HER PARTNER,
YOU KNOW, 'CAUSE WE'RE HOMIES.
KIM.
ALL THE REST ARE GONNA HATE YOU
IF YOU DON'T CHOOSE 'EM.
KIM, OKAY. YAY.
I KINDA THOUGHT I'D WON IT,
TO BE HONEST.
I HAVE BETTER STYLE
THAN MOST OF THESE GIRLS--
ALL THESE GIRLS.
OKAY, NOW, LISA, YOU GET
TO KEEP YOUR OUTFIT.
LISA, YOU ALSO GET
TO CHOOSE THREE ITEMS
THAT YOU WANT TO KEEP.
OH, MY GOD. YOUR PANTS.
AH, OKAY.
YOUR PANTS, TOO.
THIS IS SO COOL!
I WANT THOSE.
EACH OF YOU GET
TO CHOOSE ONE THING.
SEE, I HOOKED YOU GUYS UP!
I'M GONNA HAVE TO GO
WITH KYLE'S PANTS.
THOSE ARE REALLY CUTE.
I WANT DIANE'S SHOES.
WHATEVER IT IS YOU'RE TAKING,
YOU TAKE THE GIRLS
AND YOU HAVE
TO GIVE IT UP RIGHT NOW.
IT'S HARD TO SEE LISA WIN
BECAUSE SHE COMES OFF
AS A KNOW-IT-ALL, VERY BOSSY
AND A BIT SNOTTY ALSO, I THINK.
IT HAS BEEN
A REALLY FUN DAY,
AND I WANT YOU ALL TO REMEMBER,
DON'T BE AFRAID OF FASHION.
ALWAYS HAVE FUN
DRESSING UP.
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- BYE-BYE, YOU GUYS.
- BYE.
I'M GIVING POINTERS.
I MAKE THINGS
LOOK INTERESTING.
STICK YOUR NECK OUT.
PUT YOUR ARM--
IT'S ALL ABOUT ANGLES.
COMING OFF OF HER WIN,
LISA WAS A LITTLE BIT,
YOU KNOW, SHE WAS
FEELING A LITTLE GOOD.
ARE YOU LISTENING? I'M TRYING
TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
LIKE, THIS IS GONNA
WORK IN YOUR ADVANTAGE.
I WANT THIS COMPETITION TO BE
AS FIERCE AS POSSIBLE,
AND I WANT TO KNOW
THAT I WON
WITH THESE GIRLS
TRYING THEIR BEST,
LOOKING THEIR BEST
EVEN WITH MY HELP,
AND I STILL WON THAT.
THAT'S HOW I WANT IT
TO GO DOWN.
PUT YOUR FEET TOGETHER.
KEEP YOUR KNEES STRAIGHT.
BEND FORWARD.
TOUCH YOUR TOES.
YOU DO THIS.
YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
LISA WOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE VIBE
THAT WE DIDN'T WANT
TO TALK TO HER.
YOU STICK
YOUR KNEE OUT, RIGHT?
BALANCE IT OUT WITH
ANOTHER KNEE.
PUNCH IT OUT
WITH ANOTHER KNEE AND...
NO, I TOTALLY GET IT.
LISA'S EGOTISTICAL,
MODEL EXPERT MIND
IS JUST REALLY TIRING
BECAUSE SHE CONSTANTLY
- IS SHOWING PEOPLE WHAT TO DO.
- NOW, GET TO BED!
I'M GOING TO WIN
IF THAT'S OKAY BY YOU.
(laughing)
GUYS, WE HAVE TYRA MAIL.
"SEEING DOUBLE?
YOU'RE NOT LOOKING
IN A MIRROR.
BE READY AT 6 A.M."
WELL, I'M GONNA DO THE BEST
I CAN WITH THIS HAIR,
AND I THINK THAT
THEY DID IT FOR A REASON,
SO I'M GONNA TRY TO USE IT
AS AN ADVANTAGE.
6 A.M.
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO HURT ME
SO EARLY IN THE MORNING?
WE PULL UP TO THIS RANCH,
WE SEE JAY, AND I'M LIKE, OKAY,
LIKE, MAYBE WE ARE POSING
WITH TWIN SHEEP,
LIKE, CLONED SHEEP
OR SOMETHING.
- HOWDY.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT YOU ALL
TO PICK A PARTNER REAL QUICK.
PICK A PARTNER AND STAND
NEXT TO THAT PERSON.
WHO ARE YOU?
TODAY YOUR PARTNER IS
YOUR IMMEDIATE COMPETITION.
UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE CHOSEN
THE PRETTIEST GIRL
IN THE ENTIRE COMPETITION.
KYLE. GREAT.
YOU AND YOUR PARTNER
WILL BE MODELING
THE EXACT SAME OUTFIT
IN THE EXACT SAME SETUP.
YOU GUYS CAN'T WATCH
YOUR COMPETITION.
- OH!
- ALL RIGHT?
AND WE'RE GONNA SEE
WHO WORKED IT THE BEST.
TO CAPTURE A GREAT
FASHION EDITORIAL,
I HAD TO GET A GREAT FASHION
EDITORIAL PHOTOGRAPHER.
CRAIG, COME ON OUT HERE.
- GOOD TO SEE YOU.
- HI.
OH, PLEASE.
I SPENT TIME WITH EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
YOUR INDIVIDUAL STYLE.
SO I REALLY NEED YOU GUYS TO
STEP UP THE PACE AND BRING IT.
- OKAY.
- SO YOU GUYS READY?
YEAH.
SO LET'S GO BACK TO
THE HAIR AND MAKEUP TRAILERS.
I WANT IT TO LOOK COUTURE.
LIKE,
EACH AND EVERY OUTFIT.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO START
FEELING YOUR ENVIRONMENT,
FEELING YOUR WARDROBE.
I NEED HIGH FASHION,
LIKE BAM.
GOOD.
LITTLE MORE BEND
IN THE ELBOW STILL.
YES, THERE YOU GO.
I'M LIKING IT...
A LOT.
OH, BEAUTIFUL, NIK.
THAT WAS GREAT.
REALLY GOOD.
BRE, THIS IS ALL ABOUT
THAT HIGH FASHION LOOK
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
HUNCHING, WORKING THE SHAPE.
DROP THE CHIN.
THAT'S GOOD WHERE YOU ARE.
DON'T DEADPAN IT.
RIGHT. EYES CLOSE AND OPEN.
IT'S A REACTION
TO THE CAMERA.
THAT'S IT.
- LET'S BRING THE HORSE IN.
- OKAY.
SO I GUESS IF YOU'RE STANDING,
HOLDING IT LIKE THIS,
BUT YOU'RE STILL WORKING
THE DRESS, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
UM, YEAH. OH!
THE HORSE SNOTTED
ON MY DRESS.
THAT'S OKAY.
WE CAN RETOUCH THAT.
- OKAY.
- HE LOVES YOU.
SOFTEN THE LIPS.
THERE ARE SOME REAL
GOOD ONES IN THERE.
PRETTY.
THAT'S GOOD, SARAH.
THE WAY YOU'RE STANDING
RIGHT NOW JUST LOOKING AT ME
IS SO PRETTY.
CORYN, TAKE COMMAND
OF THE HORSE.
THE HORSE--HE'S REALLY
GETTING UNCOMFORTABLE
'CAUSE HE HAS
TO GO TO THE BATHROOM.
HORSE TRAINER.
YOU JUST HAVE TO TO WORK
AROUND THAT, THOUGH.
THERE YOU GO.
GREAT. GOOD JOB.
YEAH, THEY TOLD ME
I CAN'T SHOW YOU
TILL THE LAST MINUTE.
NO, THEY SAID THEY DIDN'T
WANT YOU TO SEE IT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T THINK
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE IT
BECAUSE
IT'S MORE MY STYLE.
IT'S OKAY.
WHAT WAS I THINKING?
WHY DID I GET LISA
AS MY PARTNER?
I'M MESSING
WITH YOUR MIND.
♪& WHOO-DOO-DOO-DOO ♪&
EBONY HAS REALLY BIG TA-TAS,
AND I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING,
SO THEY HAD TO DO A LOT OF
PINNING AND THIS AND THAT.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, GOOD.
NICE.
I LOVE YOUR CREATIVITY,
AND YOU'RE REALLY
GIVING ME GREAT RANGE.
I KNOW EVERY SINGLE POSE
IN EVERY SINGLE MAGAZINE
STRAIGHT UP.
♪&♪&♪&
THAT'S GOOD, THAT'S GOOD.
NICE.
(whinnies)
MOVE EVERY FRAME.
TAKE A STEP.
GOOD. DROP THE CHIN.
DON'T DO THAT SQUISHY STUFF.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WELL
MY PHOTO SHOOT IS GOING.
I'M FEELING LIKE
IT'S NOT GOING TOO GOOD,
THAT I'M NOT REALLY CAPTURING
OR UNDERSTANDING
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY
WANT ME TO CAPTURE.
HERE WE GO.
GOTTA GIVE IT SOME LIFE.
WHERE'S THAT ENERGY
YOU HAD THIS MORNING?
I'M JUST GETTING DEAD CARCASS
ON A FENCE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT
EBONY IS WHEN SHE'S GOT
ALL THIS EXCITEMENT AND
ALL THIS CREATIVITY,
AND THEN AS SOON AS EBONY
STEPS IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
IT ALL FALLS
BY THE WAYSIDE.
DO IT AGAIN.
BETTER, EBONY. KEEP IT UP.
THE ONLY THING
I'M A LITTLE BIT WORRIED ABOUT
WITH DIANE IS THAT HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO FIND AN OUTFIT
TO FIT BOTH OF US?
I ALMOST WANT YOU TO TRY
TO LIKE...
- DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- JUMP INTO IT?
JUMP INTO THE SHOT.
FEEL IT.
YOU GOT TO FEEL IT. WHOO!
- GOOD.
- AAH.
- YOU OKAY?
- YEAH, I'M FINE.
- SHE NEEDS A BAND-AID.
- OH, YOU SLIPPED?
- WE GOT A SLIP.
- SHE SLIPPED OVER THERE.
OKAY, HERE WE GO.
FILL THE FRAME.
GET SOME ANGLES
WITH THE ELBOWS.
GIVE IT SOME LIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO BRING ME
A LITTLE INTENSITY TO YOUR EYES.
SO IF YOU--EXACTLY.
NICE.
KEEP MOVING, THOUGH.
KEEP GOING SIDE TO SIDE.
NICE.
THAT'S IT. SEE THAT?
RIGHT THERE, BANG.
NICE. GOOD.
ARE YOU GONNA GIVE A MIXTURE
OF ANDROGYNY, GLAM GIRL?
I'M HANGING ON BY A STRING.
THEY'RE PUTTING ME
IN A DRESS,
THEY TELL ME I LOOK LIKE
A MAN IN A DRESS AGAIN,
THERE'S GOING TO BE
TROUBLE.
DON'T BE SO SERIOUS.
CHANGE IT UP.
GIVE 'EM SOME VARIETY
TO LOOK AT
SO IT'S NOT
ALL THE SAME. GOOD.
BUT I'M NOT GETTING SOFT
AND FEMININE OUT OF YOU.
MAKE IT WORK.
AND DON'T GET COCKY NOW.
BELIEVE ME, I WON'T.
OKAY, I NEED TO DO WELL
ON THIS. LIKE, I KNOW I CAN.
I KNEW THAT I HAD TO, LIKE,
WORK, LIKE, MY MASCULINITY
AND WITH MY FEMININITY.
RIGHT HERE, NOW.
SOFTEN THE LIPS. GOOD.
IT'S REALLY FUNNY THAT
THE FEMININE GIRL
CAN'T PULL OFF A SUIT,
BUT THE MASCULINE ONE CAN
AND MAKE IT LOOK FEMININE.
I DON'T MIND HAVING
JAYLA AS A PARTNER,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE SAID THAT
IT'S GONNA BE A COMPETITION
BECAUSE SHE KIND OF SEEMED
A LITTLE WEAK
AT THE LAST ELIMINATION.
YOU'VE BEEN STUDYING SOME
OF THEM HIGH FASHION GIRLS?
WENT THROUGH IT.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
AND YOU'RE WORKING
AND WORKING.
GOOD.
NICE. GOOD.
CASSANDRA, TIME TO BE
A LITTLE MORE
KIND OF
JUST LIKE THIS...
- YEAH.
- JUST LIKE THIS,
- NOT SO...
- YEAH.
- YEAH, EXACTLY.
- NOT SO FORCED.
TAKE A BIG INHALE
AND EXHALE.
SLUMP FORWARD.
I ALWAYS SIT UP VERY STRAIGHT
WITH MY SHOULDERS BACK,
SO I WOULD HUNCH,
AND JAY WOULD SAY,
"THAT'S NOT A HUNCH."
BUT IT FELT LIKE SUCH
A HUNCH TO ME.
LEAN INTO YOUR RIGHT HIP
INSTEAD OF YOUR LEFT HIP.
SWITCH HIPS.
THAT WAS GOOD.
LIKE, JUST STAND NORMALLY
AS IF I WAS TALKING TO YOU.
NAH, I STAND
STRAIGHT UP. OKAY.
WORKING WITH CASSANDRA
WASN'T A SUPER JOY
BECAUSE I FELT LIKE WE WERE
TRYING TO MAKE HER INTO A MODEL.
LAST FRAME.
SHE NEEDS A MIRACLE.
I DID THE BEST I COULD
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND I THINK I DID PRETTY
WELL AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT'LL MAKE UP
FOR MY ATTITUDE AT THE MAKEOVER.
TYRA MAIL!
READ IT.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 WILL
CONTINUE ON THE HOPE
OF BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
- NO TIME.
- THAT'S FOR TOMORROW?
YEAH.
OH, NO.
WHENEVER THERE'S AN
ELIMINATION, THERE'S TENSION
BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SOMEONE'S GOING HOME,
AND YOU'RE JUST HOPING THAT YOU
CAN BEAT OUT THE OTHER GIRL.
SO IT'S HARD.
I'VE TOLD YOU GUYS
IN THE BEGINNING
I WAS GOING TO WIN THIS.
I FEEL IN THE COMPETITION
I DON'T THINK
THAT I'M
THE NEXT TO GO AT ALL.
I THINK THAT THEY SEE
HOW DRIVEN I AM.
I DON'T THINK
YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT TOOK FOR ME
TO EVEN GET THIS FAR.
IF THIS DOESN'T WORK FOR ME,
THEN I'M DEFINITELY
GONNA GO BACK TO PAGEANTS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT
REALLY HELPS YOU
DEVELOP MORE AS A WOMAN
WHERE MODELING IS JUST
MORE OF A CAREER.
- WELCOME, LADIES.
- HI.
YOU GUYS HAD GLAMOROUS
MAKEOVERS THIS WEEK,
AND YOU ALSO WERE TAUGHT
HOW TO TAKE THAT MAKEOVER
AND CONNECT IT FROM YOUR HEAD
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO YOUR TOES
IN TERMS
OF YOUR PERSONAL STYLE.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR SECOND CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THESE PRIZES.
THE FIRST
IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD IN "ELLE"
MAGAZINE WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PHOTOGRAPHERS IN THE WORLD,
GILLES BENSIMON,
AN "ELLE GIRL" COVER,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL.
AND OF COURSE, WE HAVE
THESE FABULOUS JUDGES,
STARTING WITH NOTED FASHION
PHOTOGRAPHER NIGEL BARKER.
HI, GIRLS.
J. ALEXANDER,
THE FABULOUS RUNWAY COACH,
AND TWIGGY, THE LEGENDARY
FASHION ICON.
- HIYA.
- HI.
AND YOU SEE OUR
GUEST JUDGE HERE--
THE LOVELY
JAMES ST. JAMES.
JAMES IS AN ORIGINAL
CLUB KID
AND HE'S A PERSONAL STYLIST
AND AN AUTHOR.
HI, LADIES.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
GOOD.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR EVALUATIONS
AND THEN AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE WHICH OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
NOW THIS WEEK'S PHOTO SHOOT
WAS A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
YOU'LL ACTUALLY BE JUDGED
AGAINST YOUR PARTNER.
THE FIRST PAIR WE'RE GONNA
EVALUATE IS SARAH AND CORYN.
- COME ON UP HERE.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, GUYS?
WHEN YOU WALK UP TO US,
TRY AND DO IT
WITH CONFIDENCE NEXT TIME.
ALL RIGHTY, SO YOU GUYS
HAD SOME MAKEOVERS.
CORYN, WHAT WAS YOUR LOOK?
MORE SOPHISTICATED,
NOT SO CLUB.
AND THIS IS
MORE SOPHISTICATED?
THEREFORE, YOU HAVE
A FASHION VIOLATION,
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD.
AND HERE ARE BOTH
OF YOUR BEST SHOTS.
I WOULD NEVER EVEN THINK
THAT WAS SARAH ON THE RIGHT.
I THINK THE HAIRCUT HAS
REALLY TRANSFORMED YOU.
CAN WE GET
THE CLOSE-UP OF CORYN?
YOU LOOK--WAIT, CHILD!
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK A LITTLE
BIT LIKE TYRA BANKS TO ME.
YES.
I SEE IT.
KYLE AND KIM.
I LOVE THE WAY KIM MOVES.
I LOVE YOUR STYLE.
IT'S SO UNIQUE.
KYLE,
I LOVE YOUR MAKEOVER.
WHEN YOU WALKED IN,
MY EYE WAS LIKE... WHOOSH.
AND HERE ARE YOUR
BEST SHOTS.
CAN WE SEE KIM'S CLOSE-UP?
I THINK I MIGHT LIKE TO
SEE YOU FORWARD, STRAIGHT ON,
BECAUSE YOUR LAST PHOTO
WAS TO THE SIDE,
AND THIS ONE'S TO THE SIDE.
SEE, KYLE, YOU HAVE ALL
THAT IT TAKES TO BE A MODEL.
I THINK YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TRY SO HARD.
CASSANDRA AND JAYLA.
CASSANDRA, I GOTTA TELL YOU,
I'M IN LOVE WITH YOUR NEW LOOK.
- IT'S A WHOLE NEW YOU.
- YES, IT IS.
BUT WORK THAT NEW YOU
'CAUSE IT WORKS.
I'M STILL--
I'M NOT HAPPY WITH IT.
I'LL BE HONEST, BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT THE HAIRSTYLE
THAT I TOLD THEM
TO GIVE YOU.
I SPECIFICALLY SAID MIA FARROW
IN "ROSEMARY'S BABY."
I JUST WANTED FACE.
YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE RARE WOMEN
THAT I THINK COULD HANDLE IT.
- TWIGGY.
- YEAH, AND MINE WAS LONG.
I WAS IN THE SALON
FOR NINE HOURS
WHEN THEY FIRST CUT MY HAIR,
AND I WAS IN SHOCK
FOR ABOUT A WEEK,
BUT IT CHANGED MY LIFE.
THAT'S WHY SHE'S SITTING
ON THIS PANEL RIGHT NOW.
SO IF YOU DO SURVIVE
THIS WEEK, WHAT I'M GOING TO DO
IS I'M GONNA HAVE YOU
GET THE HAIRCUT
THAT I WANTED YOU TO HAVE.
IS THAT TOP CONNECTED?
WELL, IT'S ONE SHIRT,
BUT IT'S TWO LAYERS.
PULL YOUR ARMS OUT OF THE
SLEEVES AND TIE IT ON YOUR BACK.
- TIE IT ON THE BACK.
- OH, THERE WE GO.
I THINK WE HAVE
TO BURN THE BELT.
I BORROWED IT
TO LOOK MORE MOD.
THAT'S NOT MOD.
THAT'S '80s.
ALL RIGHT, MISS JAYLA.
SO YOU HAD A MAKEOVER.
IT SORT OF PULLS YOU
DOWN, I THINK.
I JUST THINK
SHE LOOKED MUCH BETTER
WITH THE SHORTER HAIR,
PERSONALLY.
SO IF YOU DO SURVIVE
THIS WEEK,
- WE'LL CUT YOURS OFF, TOO.
- ALL RIGHT.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE JAYLA THERE.
THE EYES HAVE KIND OF GONE.
IT WAS REALLY BRIGHT. I HAVE
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE EYES.
OH, I SEE.
THERE'S THE TRICK
THAT YOU DO
WHEN THE SUN IS
REALLY, REALLY BRIGHT.
KEEP THE EYES CLOSED.
YOU COUNT
ONE, TWO, THREE, BAM.
ONE, TWO, THREE,
BAM.
OKAY, CAN WE SEE CASSANDRA'S
CLOSE-UP, PLEASE?
I HAVE A FEELING
THAT CASSANDRA
WAS STILL NOT OVER HER HAIR
AT THIS POINT.
I ACTUALLY FELT BETTER ABOUT
MY HAIR IN THE PHOTO SHOOT.
I GUESS IT JUST
DIDN'T COME OFF THAT WAY.
UP NEXT, WE HAVE
EBONY AND LISA.
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL, EBONY.
ONE THING I'D SAY ABOUT
YOUR MAKEOVER, THOUGH,
IS THAT YOU PULLED IT BACK,
SO IT MAKES YOU LOOK
LIKE SOMEBODY THAT
TEACHES MODELS HOW TO MODEL.
WHY DON'T YOU TAKE
YOUR EARRINGS OFF
AND PULL YOUR HAIR DOWN
AND SHOW THE SEXINESS OF THAT?
OH, YES. OH, MY GOD.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
WOW. THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT VISION.
AND HERE ARE
YOUR BEST SHOTS.
WOW.
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
WHAT CONFUSES ME, EBONY, HERE
IS THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY GOT
NO FACE IN THIS PICTURE
WHATSOEVER.
HAIR IN THE FACE,
I THINK, IS FOR UGLY GIRLS.
WE CAN'T SEE
YOUR GORGEOUS FACE.
CAN WE SEE LISA'S
CLOSE-UP?
LISA, THAT IS STUNNING.
YOUR FACE LOOKS
CRAZY AMAZING.
HOW DID YOU LEARN
HOW TO DO THAT?
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
IN THE MIRROR SINCE I WAS 7.
GIVE ME SOME OF YOUR FACES
THAT YOU USED TO DO
IN THE MIRROR.
I JUST GO NUTS, MAN.
LIKE, YOU JUST DO EVERYTHING.
JUST WHATEVER.
AND YOU JUST KEEP GOING.
IT'S JUST LIKE WHATEVER.
- LIKE, I DON'T KNOW.
- GOOD GIRL.
NICOLE AND DIANE.
TO ME, NICOLE HAS
A REAL SEX KITTEN LOOK TO HER.
IT JUST MAKES ME THINK LIKE
NAUGHTY, NAUGHTY THINGS.
I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT.
I COULD NEVER GET AWAY
WITH THAT.
ALL RIGHT, DIANE.
I LIKE YOUR
WHOLE MAKEOVER, DIANE.
- PERHAPS THE BELT--
- I DON'T LIKE THE BELT.
IT DOESN'T REALLY WORK
FOR ME.
AND HERE ARE
YOUR BEST SHOTS.
- OH.
- WOW.
NICOLE, THIS IS THE BEST SHOT
WE'VE SEEN OF ANYBODY YET.
NO DOUBT, THAT'S GORGEOUS.
- THANK YOU.
- BEAUTIFUL.
I WANT TO GO
AND GET THAT DRESS.
I WANNA WEAR THAT
DRESS, TOO.
I SAW IT FIRST.
DIANE, I THINK YOU'RE
A LITTLE TOO RESERVED.
I THINK YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN
WITH THIS HIGH SELF-ESTEEM
AND THIS GREAT PERSONALITY,
AND IN THIS PICTURE,
YOU'RE NOT FACING THE CAMERA
AND SELLING THAT DRESS.
IT'S AS THOUGH YOU'RE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH YOUR BODY.
BUT THIS IS WHY YOU'RE HERE--
BECAUSE OF YOUR BODY.
NIK AND BRE.
SHAKE OUT THE FAUX-HAWK,
BABY.
OH, THERE WE GO. WOW.
- THERE'S A MODEL!
- THAT'S A DIFFERENT PERSON.
AND HERE ARE YOUR
BEST SHOTS.
- WOW.
OH, MY GOSH.
NIK, THAT'S FANTASTIC.
AND YOU'RE REALLY SHOWING
THE CLOTHES OFF
TO THEIR GREAT
ADVANTAGE. IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
- LET'S SEE BRE'S CLOSE-UP.
- YEAH.
THAT IS BLACK
"TOWN & COUNTRY," BABYCAKES.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, GIRLS.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
CASSANDRA, TWIGGY.
THE PHOTO HASN'T
GOT IT HERE,
BUT I'M STILL
HANGING IN THERE FOR HER,
'CAUSE I THINK
SHE'S GREAT.
I THINK THAT SHE'S A LITTLE
LOST, GENERALLY, AS A PERSON.
CASSANDRA TO ME SOMETIMES
LOOKS A LITTLE PINCHED,
LIKE SHE JUST ATE A PICKLE OR
SOMETHING.
AND NOW HER COMPETITION.
JAYLA.
- AT LEAST SHE'S TRYING.
- SHE'S TRYING.
"A" FOR EFFORT
BUT, YOU KNOW,
"C" FOR THE ACTUAL SORT
OF RESULT.
DIANE.
THERE'S SOMETHING
SORT OF UNGAINLY ABOUT HER
AND SORT OF, LIKE, GALUMPHY.
IN CASTING, SHE WAS LIKE,
"BOOBOO" AND THIS AND THAT.
- BOOBOO, WE'RE OVER HERE.
- I'M RIGHT HERE.
AND THEN SHE GETS IN HERE,
AND IT JUST MELTS AWAY,
AND IT'S LIKE,
WHERE'S DIANE?
AND NOW HER COMPETITION,
MISS NICOLE.
TO ME,
THERE'S NO COMPETITION.
THIS IS A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH,
AND SHE'S--
I THINK SHE'S GORGEOUS.
KYLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT
SHE REMINDS ME OF, GUYS?
SHE REMINDS ME OF
A SOCIALITE'S DAUGHTER.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY WHAT MODELING
USED TO BE IN ENGLAND
BEFORE I CAME ALONG
IN THE MID '60s.
I WAS THE FIRST
WORKING CLASS MODEL.
WE DON'T SAY "WORKING CLASS,"
WE SAY "GHETTO."
OH, WELL,
I'M GHETTO THEN.
- TWIGGY GHETTO.
- KIM.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU SAY
ABOUT SOME GIRLS
THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A BAD ANGLE?
KIM DOES HAVE A BAD ANGLE.
- LISA.
- THIS PICTURE OF LISA--
I LOVE THE FLUIDITY OF HER BODY
RIGHT OFF THE PAGE.
AND LISA'S COMPETITION--
MISS EBONY.
IF THIS WAS HER
BEST PICTURE,
I WOULD JUST HATE TO SEE
THE REST OF THE ROLL.
EBONY LOOKS AS THOUGH
SHE NEEDS AN ENEMA.
CORYN.
I THINK SHE'S GOING FOR BEYONCE
AND SHE GETS RuPAUL.
AND CORYN'S
COMPETITION-- SARAH.
WHAT ABOUT SAINT JOHN'S
WHATEVER?
OH, SAINT JOHN--
THE ADS FOR SAINT JOHN.
BRE.
I DON'T THINK BRE IS
BRINGING THAT PERSONALITY
TO THE PHOTOGRAPHS.
- NIK.
- HER SHAPE.
HER BOTTOM AND EVERYTHING
IS GORGEOUS.
KNICK KNACK, PADDY WHACK,
GIVE A GIRL A BUSTLE.
THE JUDGES HAVE DELIBERATED.
AND FOR EACH OF THE PAIRS
OF PHOTOGRAPHS,
WE PICKED THE STRONGEST ONE,
WHICH MEANS SIX OF YOU
DID WELL.
AND WHEN YOU SEE
YOUR FACE ON THIS SCREEN
IN THIS MAGAZINE LAYOUT,
THAT MEANS THAT YOU WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
MISS CASSANDRA,
HAY STACK HONEY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE.
WORKING
THE PRETTY PEASANT PAGE.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
CORYN.
ROCKING THE RUSTIC RUFFLES.
- CONGRATULATIONS, CORYN.
- THANK YOU.
KIM, HUNTING
HABERDASHERIES.
- YOU SEEM SAD, KIM.
- I'M JUST REALLY SURPRISED.
SORRY.
LISA, FARM HAND FATALES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
AND CLOSING OUT
OUR STORY IS NIK.
COUNTRY COUTURE.
- CONGRATULATIONS, NIK.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SO SIX LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME.
THE SIX WEAKEST PICTURES
ARE WHAT YOU ALL
REPRESENT RIGHT NOW,
WHICH MEANS ONE OF YOU
WILL GO HOME.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL--
BRE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
JAYLA.
SARAH.
CONGRATULATIONS, SARAH.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
KYLE.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
- AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL DIANE AND EBONY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO
REPRESENTS THE GIRL
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
LET'S START WITH YOU, DIANE.
THE JUDGES SEE
A GORGEOUS FACE.
WE SEE THIS BEAUTIFUL BODY,
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS BEAUTIFUL BODY
CAPTURED IN A PHOTO.
EBONY, YOU IMPRESSED ME
AT THE CASTINGS
BECAUSE YOU WERE
SO OBSESSED WITH MODELING.
BUT THE JUDGES ARE SEEING THAT
MAYBE IT'S JUST A DREAM.
DIANE.
DIANE,
WHERE'S THAT GIRL?
I KNOW SHE'S THERE.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THANKS, EBONY.
(crying)
I'M SAD THAT I GOT
ELIMINATED.
I'M HEARTBROKEN.
MODELING WAS MY DREAM.
IT'S HARD TO HEAR
THAT PEOPLE THINK,
LIKE, THAT IT'S
JUST A DREAM.
I'M TAKING THIS AS
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
THEY CLOSED THE DOOR ON ME,
BUT THAT JUST MEANS
I'M GONNA GO AND
KNOCK ON 20 OTHER ONES
UNTIL SOMEONE SAYS YES.
I THINK I'M DEFINITELY
GONNA BE OKAY.
I JUST WALKED MY FIRST STEP
TOWARD BECOMING A TOP MODEL,
AND I HAVE, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
A LOT MORE STEPS TO GO.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
A VISION IN FLIPPERS ARRIVES
TO TEACH THE GIRLS
ABOUT WORKING THE RUNWAY...
SHAKE IT BUT DON'T BREAK IT
'CAUSE THE BOYS WON'T TAKE IT.
- AND SARAH FIZZLES.
- SARAH, I NEED MORE NECK.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I DON'T HAVE MORE NECK.
AS HER RELATIONSHIP WITH KIM
BEGINS TO SIZZLE.
IF I WAS HER GIRLFRIEND,
I'D BE LIKE, "ALL RIGHT, NOW,
EXPLAIN THAT."